here again is a pretty messy expansion
to the power Tim for our review how to
write all of those out the question
they're posing to you is which of these
eleven terms because that's how many
that will be once I get to the end which
of these eleven terms has no exorcism no
excellence so they can either say is a
constant term because if there are no
exes all you're left with is numbers or
they might say the term independent of X
you seen that phrase before so in other
words all the exes from your here and
kind of cancel each other out
okay so he's the way I'm gonna go about
it the first thing I'll write is how can
I state this in synchronization as a sum
of the general term all the terms that
the same format so it's the sum from are
equals what to what where am I going
from I always start in Pascal's triangle
I always start with the zero terms and
because I'm on this road then I'm going
to go to zero one two three four all the
way up until ten you know who that okay
what about my binomial coefficient have
a look at it again I'm on the tenth row
so I'm gonna say alright which one would
you like me to write first
do you want me write this one first
yeah yeah sure why not remember it
doesn't matter okay so I can write this
minus 2 over X I can write it in that
form if you find it easier to replicate
on it how many of these am I gonna have
this is the art term right now our of
them that's fine and now I've got the
other duck guy there's 5 X to the 4 how
many of those do I have
okay now remember I said to you I can
write it either way
I wonder if you're starting to think is
there an advantage at any point to doing
it this way or the other way we'll have
a think about that as we get to it
so remember I'm searching for a turn one
of these terms has no X's in it what
will the x's cancelled out so how will I
find out you know rather than just trial
and error and yet how will I found out
find out which one it is and you take it
how can I use this knowledge in what
kind of have already uses knowledge how
can i push on it what can I do that
today or you might like to cancel a
brights
5 5 X to the 4 has to be in time squared
yes squared this guy here okay so you
actually gone straight to the answer you
were trying to match up these guys with
these guys and make sure they have
exactly the same number if you're good
at the email you can say oh well this
should be exactly the opposite number
that you can start to crunch what's
happening here mentally I can't do that
I don't know how many you can actually
do that in your head if you can if you
become comfortable not to crush that
without actually having to write you
down that's fine however he might be a
more systematic way to do it I'm
actually gonna take this guy and I'm
gonna write him back in index notation
you'll see one in a second
so if I write like so this is all of
those things um if I write this as X to
the minus 1 if you arrange something in
here to a power right what happens to
the power is like if I have something
like 2 squared and I raise that to the
house 7 what I do with these powers I
multiply them right so this is actually
be 2/3 14 because it's um 2 squared
times 2 squared times 2 squared all the
way up until you've got seven of them
right it's 14 so I'm gonna do the same
thing over here this is really X to the
minus 1 so I'm gonna have this many
negative twos and I'm gonna have this
many X's still look great
do you see what I've done with the
powers there that X to the negative 1
I've multiplied that by aa because
that's how many of them have now I've
got that anything's index notation I'm
gonna do the same thing over here
karlie fires do I have
just like I've got our of the negative
twos I'm gonna have five - ah do you see
I'm trying to separate the numbers and
the X's right now because the question
asked me something about the X's and I'm
going to provide an answer about the
numbers right how many X's are left over
how many X's if I'm not written down
that needs to belong over here remember
what I do with powers again there's this
animus so I think I have four n minus
four are X's hanging out on the end is
that okay all right now the reason this
is your school is because now I have all
of the X's kind of pushed out pull that
from where they were all tangled up and
all the other stuff right here are some
X's here and here some X's here do you
agree okay I'm going to put all the
numbers to one side and then I'm gonna
have all the X's to one side so I can
see one two three parts of this long
awful term right
there's the binomial bit there's the
first number there it's the second
number and then I've got all these X's
well now that I'm multiplying together
actually can just do an index looking
with them when you multiply numbers with
the same base what do you get what I do
with their power is I add them right so
this looks like it's gonna be X to the
4n minus 5 yep so far so good
okay now what was the question asking me
again which x term that I want it's the
one independent of X right instead I
noticed that I've written I've written
ends and that kind of thing because
that's all general actually know what it
is don't know I'm stopping
who wants ending this case is 10 right
so I actually can just write that as 10
months ah and this what's that for in
there before you win it
okay there's my 10 so in here that's
also gonna be 40 are you happy with that
okay so I've worked all this way with
this messy general term I should point
out even though it's messy it's
certainly a lot better than having
written out a little terms right okay
this is way faster okay so I can say
therefore I can now go straight to the
term that I want the time independent of
X will have well over there X to the
power of 4t minus 5r if it's independent
of X this thing up here should be
exactly zero right I should wear non
zero that was what it would mean if all
of these guys cancel with each other
okay so I will have 40 minus 5 on equals
zero that's what I want right I want all
of those indices to exactly cancel out
so I will have no X's anymore little X's
means I'll just have one two three
numbers right and they're independent of
X numbers are interrelated of X we can
so far can't we what's that going to
equal to so that's the term I'm after
I'm just going straight there okay which
is actually what I was saying before
that eight and four okay
but sometimes these numbers are not
quite so obvious and maybe you can see
it before like I couldn't so now I've
gone straight there just by solving with
the power
so therefore the term is now because I'm
now saying the term I didn't have to
write Seema Seema means out of all of
them right because this thing really
does have a lemon terms in it but now
I'm just going to the eighth term so I'm
going to say it and see eight times what
what else have I got in the general term
up there negative two to the eighth
times 5 to 10 minus 8 which is 2 here we
go I've no idea what this is consumer
tell me what it equals it this is the
only bit that I don't actually know the
rest of it we can work out that's the
whole thing yeah can I get some
confirmation thumbs up okay so can we
just rewind a little bit what we've done
is who said I can't any time you want to
go for a specific term which is
primarily when this power is ridiculous
and you're like I don't want to write
this whole thing out
you can go specifically to one by using
the general term what we mean by the
general tribe is every term generally
speaking every term looks like this you
just change what R is and then you'll go
from one term to the next once you've
got the general term every now you can
pull it apart and pull it apart take the
X's out onto one side do so mum index
laws on them and then you can single
that guy out find out where he's equal
to zero or find out whether it's equal
to 2 or 8 or whatever number they're
interested in and then you just evaluate
that term directly okay far more
efficient I didn't even need to evaluate
the X term because we know it's not
gonna have any bits to it okay